[Music]
are you Jeffrey Katzenberg yeah do you
mind if I ask you a question or a couple
questions yeah but I think you're gonna
do it anyway so go for it
so anything you want to tell me about
that new company you've started a very
exciting new TV make a super premium
mobile content for everybody and this
would be only for smartphone that phone
well I have to hold my phone like well I
have to put my phone like this you hold
the way you want to any way you want to
okay different content different ways
hmm what was the hardest thing about
leading DreamWorks letting go you know
passing the baton you know having your
child move on most thrilling moment at
Disney I take the Renaissance of
animation bringing bringing that back
and ten years was really incredibly
gratifying Aladdin or Little Mermaid Oh
Little Mermaid part of your world and
Ariel and the sea and what movie has her
favorite vision of the future the first
Star Trek was had the first cell phone
in it but et told me that when the
aliens arrived they're going to be our
friends there's a lot of attention right
now on how women are being treated in
Hollywood what's one way to change the
culture don't accept it
what's one thing you wish your phone did
but doesn't do now not drop calls can
you hear me now
again there you are maybe they can work
on that technology that would be nice
ten years from now where are we watching
video in my glasses we're all watching
video in your glasses every single
person is watching video in my glasses
or on new TV
the other do you know how I can get a
free ticket to Disneyworld call Bob Iger
I'm sure I'll help you out do you know
yeah but you call it all right looks
like this is you see ya see ya
you